bonjour et merci d'être avec nous se
fera alors le soudan du sud s'élève donc
les dix ans de son indépendance mais on
a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les sud
soudanais n'ont rien à fêter puisque la
crise humanitaire est pire qu'avant la
scission avec le soudan est ce que
finalement cette indépendance a eu lieu
beaucoup trop tôt triste anniversaire
que bolide a pris 10 ans d'indépendance
comme l'a rappelé vos diaporamas juste
avant que je passe à l'antenne sous les
il ya eu quand même des guerres civiles
extrêmement importante et où de
nombreuses personnes ont perdu la vie si
on peut dire donc et notamment mais
aussi sept succès d une période
intéressante de 2005 à 2011 où justement
une autodétermination du sne au dessus
des lettres décidé donc entre 2005 et
2011 tout avait été mis en place pour
préparer ses dépenses donc c'était ce
n'était pas trop tôt revanche ce qui a
été très mal préparés si certaines
dépendances avec des rivalités de
pouvoir qui sont apparus très rapidement
et surtout un processus de paix qui n'a
pas abouti si l'on peut dire deux
exemples pour montrer que ça n'était que
très mal préparée
c'est quid de la manne pétrolière vous
avez une zone qui s'appelle une de la
zone d'habiller dans laquelle la
frontière n'a toujours pas été
déterminée et une zone très riche en
pétrole et qui a fait dans l'objet de
rivalités et donc émission d'une mission
des nations unies s'était planté là
c'est la fiche du mans avec 4000 hommes
à peu près pour une faire en sorte que
ce cette zone à se stabiliser
en attendant qu'un jour ou l'autre la
frontière soient établies et le deuxième
point c'est quid de la manne fille
pétrolière vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure aussi que faisons que fait-on du
pétrole c'est bien de le sortir de la
terre faut-il encore le transporter et
le raffiné ce que n'avait pas pensé les
soudanais du sud sudan et c'est qu'il
fallait peut-être utilisé des
installations il valait fall et
désinstaller les utiliser ces
installations du soudan donc il a fallu
avoir des rivalités s'ils ont payé entre
le soudan et le soudan du sud pendant
les deux premières années d'arriver au
pouvoir pour qu'on stabilise cette
situation donc aujourd'hui s'est
stabilisé il ya une subvention qui sans
donner le prix du pétrole au baril quand
ils ne se sont pas donnés à l'état
soudanais
mais voyez que tout ça c'était très mal
préparé donc pas trop tôt mais très mal
préparée alors on sait quand on comprend
de vue sur politique en février 2020 un
gouvernant
d'union nationale a été formé avec
notamment salva kir au poste de
président réal machart à celui de vice
président il y avait des mesures qui
avaient été préconisées dans cet accord
avec la reconstitution du parlement une
réforme de la constitution est également
pourquoi jusqu'à maintenant voilà le
pays n'a pas avancé
politiquement aux blancs parce que vous
avez toujours le même problème la
rivalité entre le président salva kir et
un de ses vice-présidents qu'eric
machart l'aurait président l'autre veut
sa place donc les prochaines élections
vont être assez tendu quand elles auront
lieu en 2023 mais c'est déjà des
rivalités qui ont donné l'accord de paix
de 2015 on vous avait parlé tout à
l'heure et en même temps comme cet
accord est épuré assez régulièrement
et rappelez-vous de l'accord de 2015 le
premier accord de paix avait été signé
par les deux protagonistes dans des
lieux complètement différent des dates
différentes
ça voulait dire que déjà tout le monde
se moque éperdument de cet accord de
paix il a été revitalisé en 2018 pour
essayer de donner un nouveau souffle
si on peut dire la communauté
internationale c'est extrêmement
impliqué dans cette affaire là mais ce
que leurs marques
est-ce que des nations unies remarqué
dans le dernier rapport au dollar margot
c'est la lenteur avec laquelle le
gouvernement aujourd'hui à travailler
depuis l'accord de paix de 2018
donc c'est un gouvernement unifié en
2020 février 2020 et un parlement qui
vient juste d'être nommée wii donc que
l'état commence à se construire si l'on
peut dire
mais avec grande lenteur et ont repris
les combats sur le terrain que ce soit
entre sympathie rachat mais aussi avec
des groupes armés dissidents si l'on
peut dire qu'il se recréer donc vous
avez aussi une fragmentation de ces
groupes armés qui fait que la situation
est délétère si l'on peut dire est que
vous avez aujourd'hui de 8 millions de
la population qui demande qui a besoin
d'eux
humanitaire donc c'est le diaporama de
dépasser au début qui montre que l'état
est loin d'être satisfaisant puisque 8
millions sur 11 millions d'habitants ça
fait à peu près les deux tiers
la situation est encore pire qu il y a
dix ans selon plusieurs analystes
politiques on parle aussi d'une des
crises humanitaires les plus graves au
monde
il ya également la crise sanitaire aussi
qui entre aujourd'hui en jeu quels sont
les pays frontaliers du soudan du sud
qui pourraient venir en aide justement à
ceux plus jeune pays du monde alors au
départ tout le monde était favorable à
intervenir si l'on peut dire
l'organisation régionale c'est à dire
l'autorité intergouvernementale pour le
développement ce qu'on appelle l'igad a
tout fait pour que ces processus de paix
arrive si l'on peut dire à échéance 2015
comme des mecs 18 c était soutenu par
légal les américaines seraient
énormément impliqué aussi mémé pays
frontaliers aussi l'ethiopie et le kenya
même s'il est un petit peu plus loin
parce qu'on a mis directement se sont
impliqués mais à un certain moment entre
2011 si l'on peut dire et 2015
l'ouganda qui est aussi membre de cet or
est sensuelle jouer sans double jeu
aussi bien dans l'organisation régionale
que dans ses relations il fait chaud
dans du très proche oui donc c'est
extrêmement difficile et la situation
aujourd'hui de la totalité de la corne
de l'afrique fait que très peu de gens
peuvent venir en aide si on peut dire à
ce sont du sud 1 évoquons simplement pas
très loin les problèmes éthiopiens
erythréens du soudan aussi mais aussi
d'un somalie donc c'est une région
extrêmement perturbé on peut pas trop
compter sur les partenaires frontaliers
pour arriver à trouver une solution
donc c'est les nations unies qui
interviennent si l'on peut dire avec
deux missions à ne pas oublier que vous
avez en même temps que la force
intérimaire de sécurité des nations
unies la fils tu m'as dans la petite
région d'abyei et dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure vous avez aussi une mission des
nations unies au soudan le sud pour
aider l'état à organiser ces élections à
distribuer l'aide humanitaire est
protégé à protéger la population civile
c'est une force 16 mille hommes et donc
des nations unies en vie quand même
énormément de moyens dans la sphère si
l'on peut dire l'aide humanitaire avec
le hcr le cicr continue nous allons
quand même du mal à ce que les
partenaires qui sont très forts au
niveau de 1 de l'entourage proche si
l'on peut dire soudan sud puissent
intervenir
donc le soudan du sud devra un petit peu
géré sa gouvernance tout seul sans trop
d'implications des partenaires
extérieurs
on a cru un moment que la situation
s'est améliorée entre le soudan et le
soudan du sud puisque l'accord de paix
du soudan avec les groupes d'opposition
a été signé à juba donc des relations
sont meilleures si l'on peut dire mais
vous avez vu la situation du soudan
aujourd'hui elle ne peut pas venir en
aide si on peut dire au soudan du sud
merci beaucoup en tout cas pas très fier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
géopolitique spécialisé sur la corne de
l'afrique